but now do you you have a trick to get
into it do you yeah absolutely so
when i was preparing i didn't know a
dairy accent first off and then i
thought who do i know and then i thought
oh nadine from girls aloud is extremely
dairy and then
i don't know if people will know this
but there was an extremely controversial
incident in the early 90s in ireland
so good it was so good i feel like it
was the first irish sort of pop culture
tv moment it was
pop stars the irish version which only
had about 50 entrants because we don't
have as big a population
so she went on and lied about her age
but she got found out on camera
stop it yes youtube it's so good
okay so she's gotten into the band and
then her
on camera interview like the first one
to introduce yourself who you are she
said
madam's the dean coyla from lark hill
and there he did a birthday the 685
mecca me and germany
and then she thinks for a second and
goes what dinner birthday so you know
fifteenth of the second
and then it fades and she's she's she's
outed herself on camera
but everyone lost the plot do the phone
call to her mother
do everything mommy do the whole thing
daddy put my passport in the car
mommy will you look at my handbag for my
passport and it was all a lie she knew
she was 16 she was meant to be 18. what
is it about you lot pretending you're
different ages
cool isn't it cute because she wanted to
make it through that's but then but then
she got and girls allowed it actually
worked out much better
you see yeah yeah and we ended up with
an amazing moment of her sobbing in the
back of a renault spas being driven away
you